the only place this really is
controversial is in washington dc people
get afraid of their base but guess what
your base loves pot sales are expected
to grow 28 percent questions about the
timeline for federal legalization some
states and communities are hoping that
pot once considered a gateway drug could
now become a gateway for economic and
racial justice this hypocrisy these drug
laws that we have that are archaic and
uh cruel uh they must end and i'm gonna
fight to make sure right now
uh that this ugliness is over in our
country and we do the right thing on the
federal level and our momentum is
building by the way when you think of
cannabis reform most people historically
would think it's a democratic issue but
what has been happening slowly is that
this issue is is not a red or blue issue
at all nancy mace is a freshman
congresswoman
from south carolina she worked for the
trump campaign eventually became a state
house representative in south carolina
before being elected to congress in 2020
in november she introduced the state's
reform act which if passed would end the
federal prohibition on cannabis mesa's
bill is perhaps the most comprehensive
republican-backed bill to end the
federal prohibition against marijuana
what's noteworthy about the state's
reform act is is twofold it first is
that it's introduced by a republican the
second noteworthy thing about this bill
is who's supporting it you have one of
the world's most powerful conservative
groups americans for prosperity founded
by the billionaire charles koch then you
also have one of the world's largest
companies amazon which just came out in
support of her bill you can't do
cannabis reform in washington without
republican and democrat support and so
what i hope to do with this bill is
provide a proof of concept a framework
that has something for everybody whether
you have an r or a d by your name you
know if you don't like cannabis well
we're not forcing it on you we're not
forcing your state to legalize it so
everybody can use it everywhere right
that's not what this bill does and so it
has provisions in there that
conservatives and and liberals you know
both sides of the aisle
can really i think get on board with but
it's just people get afraid they get
afraid of real action and they operate
out of fear
[Music]
some people you know wonder why why does
why is a republican so passionate about
cannabis i was raped when i was 16
and subsequently i dropped out of school
and it was one of the darkest times in
my life i became a waitress at the
waffle house on the side of the
interstate at that time and i really
felt like i had no answers i had no
future but i was prescribed by my doctor
anti-depressants and the antidepressants
i was prescribed made my feelings of
depression worse it made me suicidal
quite frankly and i stopped taking the
prescription drugs and i started using
cannabis but it cut my anxiety down and
helped me get through some really tough
times and that was my first sort of you
know understanding and realization that
there's something here that could
benefit people and when i talk to
veterans especially when i hear their
stories coming back from conflict coming
back from a theater combat and war zones
the ptsd that they have the thoughts
that go through their mind of wanting to
end it all it really really it touches
my heart because
i was in a place where
i've been there
70 of americans believe that marijuana
should be legal so
democrat republican
voters want this but this is a place
where republicans should really lean in
on because it's a popular idea
and it's past time i mean you look at
some of the the folks uh that have major
major illnesses and see how their lives
have been impacted by cannabis in in a
positive way and we can't fully study
cannabis right now for medical reasons
for example because it's a schedule one
we're treating it like heroin
which is a crazy idea when people might
want to use it for going to sleep at
night versus using a prescription drug
like ambien for example and they're just
so many different uses the elephant in
the room here is that this bill is
unlikely to pass as
our other cannabis reform measures
however
what what congresswoman mace is
attempting to do is to to show that
cannabis can be a republican issue and
also show that there might be enough
republicans on board to pass cannabis
reform
you